uh yes I had the advantage that the
previous speakers introduced quite well
some of the key concept for constraint
programming uh so that'll save me time
but I'll try to relate back to these
talks uh when I can
so here's the plan of this talk so I'll
first again
uh make the point that we've got exposed
coming natural structure from the high
level models in CP and that can be very
useful as I've mentioned before and
argued for
and I'll focus on new well relatively
new things that we can do from that
those constraints and structure so
namely counting and weighted counting
you'll see why
when we come to D the third part about
the CP BP framework so basically CP
solvers where you mix it with with
belief propagation because you're you've
got a richer propagation media I'll come
to that and give you some examples and
why that can be useful okay
yeah so
um
so one could say that among the model
based uh combinator solving paradigms uh
CP sort of took the The Road Less travel
and most uh other approaches set integer
programming uh I would imagine ASP as
well I think
have
models typically lots of constraints in
a simple syntax and lots of them whereas
CP tends to have more
concise models but with uh
where its original Syntax for those
constraints and
um and so each constraint represents a
bigger shock on the problem as as you
you've seen in some of the previous
talks okay
here are two example models the first
one uh Ron robin tournament where you're
defining some variables and some some
constraints are simple you've got even
unary constraint here and so the binary
constraints but the most of the
combinatural structure of your problem
is represented in those global
constraints or larger Rarity constraints
that such as the all different here so
we have several all different
constraints and regular constraints
you'll hear about that later on that's
where your structure is and maybe you
can exploit exploit that we do actually
I'm I'm proposing to go even further
another example here where you're moving
furnace is a scheduling problem really
you have two resources uh handlers and
trolleys and that you need to use and
again most of the problem I mean this is
the whole model most of the problem is
represented by these cumulative
constraints John mentioned uh this
morning cumulative scheduling so that's
a big chunk of your problem is
represented there okay
so I would argue again maybe that the
distinctive driving force of CP is this
direct access to problem structure from
the high level modeling that we use okay
in the end we may be using you know a
stat solver possibly or something but
you you start off with a high level
representation and that gives you or
gives CP sometimes an edge in in how to
solve the problem
uh
how does one identify nominate these
high level constraints uh I would say
that over time looking at applications
you identify structures that are complex
enough
to provide structural Insight but that
are
simple enough that you can that the
things you the tasks you want to perform
on them are tractable most of the time
and there are some exceptions uh but
that's typically how you decide okay
this would be an interesting constraint
that we can use in different problems
for to solve different problems to
express
to model these problems and then solve
it
what sort of thing do we do with these
constraints well traditionally you as
Kieran said at least you want to know
given a constraint C is there any
solution to that constraint or is this a
solution to constraint uh the domain
filtering The Arc consistency that you
heard about uh we're asking is is there
any solutions to the constraint so the
constraint level such that variable X
takes value D so is that assignment
supported or should it be removed from
the domain as you saw in previous talks
other things what I want to focus on are
these questions so how many solutions
are there to see so you want to count to
Solutions
or even more so how many solutions in
which X takes the value d
in what in what proportion of these
Solutions
and that can also be quite uh
interesting to compute
okay
um
simple example here let's say you have a
binary constraint okay over variables X
and Y that grid here
every Row in that grid would represent a
value possible value for y and a a
column a value for x okay let's say that
you've got the green dots represent the
solution to that particular constraint
so if you have so you may have an
initial domain for X that's a blue
segment here interval one for y
one way to look at
domain filtering that we do the
inference that we do is while you're
projecting these Solutions along the
axis and you get the reduced green
intervals here so you've got a subset
saying okay these values are supported
the others are not there's no value for
x there's no solution using this value
for x so it could be filtered out so
that's what you want to do ideally
typically in CP okay
but that's only part of the the the
picture
um with the same so consider a totally
different set of solutions here for
another constraint this one
it has exactly the same support okay
projections are the same so if you just
look at that information the outside
information you get from projecting from
the domain filtering
you don't really distinguish between the
two uh
the two sets a solution to two
constraints really okay well what if we
worked a little bit harder
and computed the frequency counts over
the values okay
so now uh
these okay so these These are the
supported values but this occurs three
times in three solutions this Intrigue
to
so you get a discrete distribution over
the domain so now all of a sudden you're
getting more information instead of
having okay these values are possible
but
from our perspective equally likely here
you're getting additional information
well this one is maybe more likely to be
useful because it is very popular it
occurs very often in an assignment to
this uh a solution to this constraint
and actually for example you could use
the mode of those distribution as a
branch in your system because let's try
out this value
so that's the type of thing that we want
to compute
uh
and well so the other constraint here
would have a so a different distribution
in different modes So you you're getting
you're distinguishing these two
constraints here okay
technically what you want to do is to
count Solutions here you want for
example to know that well 5 out of 22
Solutions use this value okay
so you want to count Solutions and
that's why I'll spend some time here uh
looking at
counting and weighted counting you have
to trust me at first why we want to do
weighted counting it'll become clear
later on
uh
and I'll give you examples of
constraints uh illustrating for the the
techniques we've been using so far to to
perform the counting okay so again the
initial uh
uh
we start from a constraint is something
that traditionally what we want to do is
trackable is easy to do that's the maybe
the inference for the domain filtering
maybe sometimes it's the same thing for
counting maybe not so as we will see
okay
so the first uh case is where we have
we're fortunate in that the we have a
compact representation of the set of
solutions to a constraint
I'll use a particular person the regular
constraint here but and you'll see
similarities with exact decision
diagrams that John mentioned this
morning where he had there was a compact
representation of the of potential so
polynomial size of potentially an
exponential number of solutions because
basically you're you're sharing edges
okay I'll I'll recall that but let me
first Define what the regular constraint
is takes its name from regular languages
so uh uh automata here so that regular
constraint over a finite sequence of uh
of finite domain variables X1 to x k
it holds if that sequence spells out a
word recognized by the automata by the
regular language okay
uh so for example I've got the uh
automaton here I'm using so seven states
initial State one and I'm using Color
strips and values so on the value red
you go from State one to state two and
so on I think everybody's familiar with
automata okay
now
um what do we do for filtering here
because I'll just mention that because
we'll see that we don't need much more
to do Counting
uh it works as follows so you you start
with the automaton here
and you build this Dag
uh so you've got layers of nodes here in
your dag there's one layer per uh in
between the number of layers depends on
the number of variables uh really so
you've got a variable identified with
the the transition from one layer to the
next where the variable and here are
your states of your automaton and you're
basically on this is the uh say the the
domain of the variable so X1 can take
value red green yellow so forth you're
unfolding the automaton uh over the
domain there over the sequence of
variables so you start an initial state
is one so on value yellow you stay at
one so you get a straight edge on Value
Green you go to state three so that's
there and so on you extend from there
all the way to the end
that's the forward pass and backward
notice that for example here this does
not lead to anything in the last layer
so there's a backward pass you clean up
and you get
something that looks a lot like those
decision diagrams if you look at it
sideways okay here basically
um and it has uh the nice property again
as well that there's a one-to-one
correspondence between paths from the
first the initial state to the last
layer and solutions to your constraint
if you're good at compact representation
and you may not have seen noticed but
between this so when you do the the
backward pass
you had the green value was possible for
many variables and it can be filtered
out because corresponding arcs don't
appear anymore when you clean up okay
now but you really want to do counting
on this so how do you do it
um so you've got this layered graph well
you just need to work a little bit
harder you maintain some information at
each node
a pair of numbers so the
the number of incoming paths from the
initial State at a node
and the number of outgoing paths to the
final state to a final State okay so for
example here that means that there are
two incoming
fast from the end there are two outgoing
ones okay from there there's one there
and there's one like that okay that's
that's an easy recursion to compute that
so that's not much effort
and once you have that well uh if you
want to count all solutions
as a side effect if you look for example
at the first the initial State you could
look at the final States as well well
you've got 19 outgoing paths to the
final size so we've got 19 Solutions
okay what if uh I want to I really want
to know uh well how many not many
solutions is X3 taking the value red
okay you want to compute this this
marginal bias depending on your the
terminology you're familiar with so I'll
notate this as Theta of extreme
of red
well you've got 19 Solutions in all
what do you do you look at the RX
corresponding to the layer for X3 here
you look at all the red arcs
and you want to know how many paths go
through one of these red arcs here
corresponding to a value red being
assigned to X3 well you just you so you
look at that this is the first red R you
take the end points incoming is one
times outgoing is two that's two
then the second red Arc incoming two
outgoing two two times two that's four
in all and so on
and so you find out that you've got 10
over 19
Solutions using value red for variable
X3
so you can see this as being a the
marginal probability of X pre equal red
if a solution is selected uniformly at
random okay so the good news is that it
doesn't cost you much more here
if you're doing the work to for
filtering Counting
costs you almost nothing more okay
what if you want to do weighted counting
for reasons that will be become clear
later on as I said well basically uh you
change so each art has a weight it's not
in the on the picture but uh and the
weight of a path is a product of the art
weights okay well you just maintain
different formation making the sum of
weighted incoming paths and some
outgoing paths and there's a small
change to recursion but basically it's
not harder to do that okay
so that's when you're lucky it doesn't
cost you much more you already have a a
a a a compact representation of the
solution set uh but you don't
necessarily have that remember the all
different constraints you've seen this a
few times already
so all the the values taken by these
variables must be different
um you've got this value graph variables
on one side and values on the other and
you were told you know it's equivalent
to looking at for a complete matching
um you can also view it on the adjacency
Matrix so you're looking to pick a one
in every row such that they're in
different columns okay equivalently so
this matching here in red would
correspond to these ones being selected
here
okay very useful constraint
uh we know that it's it's domain
filtering doesn't cost you much as
you've seen before okay great
but counting Solutions cost you
significantly more if you want to do it
exactly
uh so the number of solutions is
one speaker alluded to that I forget who
uh
it's the same so it's the number uh
you're looking for the number of perfect
matchings in the bar by type graph
that's equivalent on The adjacency
Matrix to the Computing the permanent of
that Matrix
and that's hard I think someone said
actually that it was Sharpie I think
Kieran maybe so that's uh it's a Sharpie
complete problem so you're out of luck
so it's you can't uh Solve IT
efficiently under uh reasonable
theoretical assumptions
so what do you do well fortunately it's
a well-studied problem probably the
permanent so
uh there are known estimators to compute
it
um here's here's a one and I think it'll
be easier I'll just show you an example
of how how it works
um but it's basically looking oops
looking at
um the uh the the ones in a row goes row
by row look at a number of ones picks
one uniform at random and
recursively but computers say a a
product of the number of ones that are
in every row so
example here
so first row you've got three ones you
pick one at Universe uniform at random
for example this one here the one and
you note here that you had three ones
you go on while you remove that row
you're done and you remove the column
you can't pick ones in that column
anymore
and then next step well there's only one
one there's no choice
and then there's only one one that's the
only one you can pick
again here you go the choice between two
let's say you pick the last one
and you're done and you take the product
and it gives you an estimate of the uh
number of social happens to be the exact
one here but that's a very small problem
so that estimator uh it works well
according to restaurants so it works
well for almost all dense matrices and
so much for sparse made receipts
for results in some special cases of
dance matrices this one the upper
triangular one
you may notice that there's only one
solution possible I mean this one
doesn't have any choice so this one we
will have to take so these are the
values on the diagonal but your the
estimator will
fail most of the time right because it
starts with the first row and picks one
at random if it picks the wrong one
where they're done
um okay
well what we do here we add the main
filtering so we have the estimator here
and you just add before picking
uh one of the ones you just you add the
main filtering uh to uh to rule out
these possibilities and that helps quite
a bit uh helps avoid the dead end so
improves the estimator and then we can
use you know that estimate as for a
number of solutions and when you want to
do the know the marginals the
proportions well we can look at the ones
that have what we're looking for so from
our Earth sampling
okay so that's another push we use for
in some cases
oh in the weighted case again here not
much more uh difficult so your entries
are now non-negative
and
um you are choosing
randomly but according to the
distribution giving by the weights
basically and and here you're you're not
multiplying by the number of one while
you're you're one you're multiplying by
the sum of these these non-negative
entries
okay good
uh
now we can also use in some cases some
existing theoretical result let's stay
with the another approach let's stay
with the all different
um the sampling can still be expensive
to do because you have to do it you know
if you do it at every node of your
search tree it can get to be expensive
depending how many samples you're you're
collecting
uh I told you the permanent is a
well-studied problem well uh they're
also known upper bounds on the permanent
on the zero one for zero one matrices so
in the case of the unweighted case
um and they're pretty simple
um they rely on the number of basic
those are the Expressions on number of
ones in the rows I don't want to go into
the details but they're fast to compute
a lot of these these functions can be
pre-computed
um so that's the the good news and even
in the weighted case where you've got
some non-negative entries there are also
known upper bounds okay with these
things can be uh I'm going to give me a
function G here but that that can be
pre-computed so that's that's fast uh to
use
but I really want to tell you about uh a
uh another one another constraint and a
nice theoretical result here the
spanning tree constraint so uh so you're
given a graph and uh you have a set
variable so T which is a subset of the
edges of your graph and the spanning
free constraint as that t must be a
spanning tree of G okay very standard so
given the graph here on this on the left
uh this is one example of a spanning
tree but I graph and if you want all of
them here are all the other ones okay
and I've put some edges in color because
um well you're interested in okay how
many spanning trees use the yellow Edge
or how many use the red Edge for example
okay can I answer that question
and so here's where Theory comes in so
there's a nice theorem called The Matrix
tree theorem that we can use
um so first given a graph
we can use a matrix representation
called The Liberation of that graph
basically you can look at it as being
the adjacency Matrix where instead of a
one you have a minus one
and on the diagonal you have the degree
of the vertex
so here you've got an edge the red Edge
is represented between V1 and V5 is
represented here and in terms of degree
the end point here B1 is degree three
and V V5 as degree two okay
so the result is that any any minor of
the laplation so you remove one row one
column take the determinant
any row any column
so the any minor is equal to number of
spanning trees in absolute value okay
so for example here I've taken out the
first row First Column take the
terminate 21 trust me they were 21 spine
increase before okay
so it's easy to to so it's relatively
cheap it's it's a determined computation
to get the number of spanning trees
right that's a very cute result
but we're interested in even more so in
County Solutions involving an edge so
here it'll be easier to say so this is
excluding a given Edge and we'll come
back to including it afterwards so I
want to know
um spanning trees
in from graphs where I remove one five
with respect to
all the spanning trees
that's the location for the your graph G
that's a location where you move this
Edge well only four entries change the
green entries those the only one that's
changed the end the degree of the end
points and the the edge
so and these four entries even if the
Matrix very big the grass is very big
they are on in two columns and two rows
okay
so I'm interested in taking a minor so
if I take the minor and I remove
you know one of these rows and columns
where those changes appear
then what I'm left with something that's
very similar to the original laplation
it's only one entry that's different now
so I'm Computing a determinant of
something that's almost the same Matrix
there's one and three different well
there's a formula for this that says
that
if so what's the determinant of this
Matrix that's almost like m well it's
related but it's from that to the
determinant of M so and in in our case
it simplifies to
1 minus the the entry Json from the
diagonal of the inverse of Matrix M
times the determinant now remember that
we're interested in that ratio
well that's this over this the
determinant disappears and you get
something very elegant I find
one so and that's for excluding The Edge
so if if I want to count the know the
proportion of including that edge it's
one minus that so it's this
so you only need you need to invert The
Matrix of your the
ablation and and look at the entries of
the diagonal
so for example here
um
so you've got this graph so you can
basically you need to do Matrix
inversion uh for uh one meters for all
the edges incident to particular vertex
so you do that so if you have a Vertex
cover maybe you can that gives you how
many you have you need to do uh so for
example in this graph
if I invert it I see that the yellow
Edge appears in 12 over 21.
sliding trees the blue edge and 10 over
21 and the red Edge 13 over 21. so
Matrix inversion and you're getting
counting the proportion so
very good
hey
I'll go quickly over this because it's
it's also very nice what about minimum
styling tree okay uh
so now your edges have weights
and here are all the trees have cost
five cost six you do something similar
except that your laplation
is generalized
so here you don't have minus ones you
have mine so you you've got uh
polynomials in univariable polynomials
here you've you've got minus x to the
power determined by the weight of that
edge
the degree well is the sum of the so
you've got a V1 is degree uh three but
it's got one edge of weight two three
one so it's six two plus six three plus
X1
and if you apply the same theorem
Something Beautiful happens uh so if you
compute the determinant you get this one
here
and then that sort of spells out
so you look at the the lower degree term
so each uh trinomial here each term uh
that tells you the coefficient tells you
how many spine increase and the exponent
the cost of the tree so you've got three
spanning trees that cost five six have
cost six and so on
so
quite pretty uh
security costs uh
and here uh so in practice we don't
compute those determinants over over
polynomials what we do is we fix x uh
some value between 0 and 1 that sort of
favors uh uh lower cost trees and you
your fall back to the scalar entries let
me do that as usual okay
okay
um okay
um domain relaxation a few words
um
that's like constraint you've heard
about those before we could do them
as regular as decision diagrams thing is
it
it runs now in studio polynomial time
it's sensitive to the magnitude of your
bounds the numbers here L and U so you
could do that if the numbers are not too
big otherwise uh while you could in a
nutshell you basically relax the domains
to intervals and assume that the values
are uniformly distributed and and
since you're looking at a a sum here of
a random variables say a premier from
distribution you get a nice normal
distribution you can you can use that as
an approximation okay I really want to
get to this part here
so I've been telling you about counting
weighted counting what can we do with
that okay uh
so I want to move Beyond standard
support propagation so what we call
constraint propagation but you're
basically propagating which values in
the domains are still supported
and I want to move to belief propagating
beliefs or marginals
uh okay what is this picture uh the blue
rectangle and the red rectangle are two
constraints
um so the first the blue constraint is
on variables X Y and Z and the other one
and x y w and z and you have the domains
a b c d e
it's discrete distribution the probably
Mass function on all over the domain so
that more
informative uh
let me see information that's redundant
okay so you so you want to
propagate that information so saying
that okay instead of propagating that c
is not supported I'll say well my belief
is that the distribution over the domain
of X so as as to which are good values
is such the red constraints has the same
thing but doing well something different
the other way and hopefully
you iterate and hopefully you get to
maybe some agreement or converge to
something or okay to get more of a
global
picture
and uh and that corresponds to you need
to the weighted model counting to do
this an example
um
so that's a simple problem you've got
constraints over variables a b c d
domains one two three four
three constraints and all different sum
and a binary inequality
if you apply constraint
if you do some filtering here trying to
do some inference and standard wind
nothing happens the domains are still
are uh keep all their values okay
what we want to do here is say Okay I
want to compute the marginal for value
for variable C
in the blue constraint for Value three
well this is simple we can do it by hand
so there are two solutions that support
seating in value three D D should take
value 3 or 4. okay so these are the two
possibilities so equal weight here so
I've got two out of 10 possible
solutions this okay
so that goes into a big so I do this for
every variable for every constraint
involved so you can fill out this big
table and notice that for example uh for
um variable D the black constraint the
sum says well value one is a good good
choice 10 over 20 but 4 is a bad choice
the blue constraints is the opposite one
over ten four over ten okay saying oh no
so they may disagree that's why you want
to propagate the information and
readjust so you compute this
uh so a variable will take the point of
view of each constraint you multiply it
normalize it then you get the current
marginals current beliefs for as to its
values okay
that's the so you do that for every so
after one iteration you have something
like this
then it becomes more interesting you do
it again but now so you recognize this
but now the solutions won't have the
same weight because according to the
black constraint D taking value 3 is
occurs in three out of 20 Solutions
value four and one out of 20. so those
are the weights that's why you need the
weighted counting Solutions are not
weighed the same
through the assertive process and then
you get eventually say here in 10
iterations
you get these so then a pattern starts
to emerge it tells you that well it's
very according to the computation very
likely that C and D will take value one
and about half and a half values two and
three for a and b
that's actually in this simple case very
close to true marginals there are only
two solutions you may have figured out
already two three one one or three two
one one those would be the true
marginals so about 50 50 here and and
one there and that's what we had okay so
you're getting more information you can
iterate and that can help you
um get get a better picture of of what
where the solutions are so
um
you can use it to Branch for coming at
all search and we've done that I've
alluded to that before saying talking
about the mode
so we typically do binary branching in
CP so
XI takes about the DJ or excite
does not take value in sub J
um you can do a number of things with
that information what we currently like
is doing Min entropy so how do we choose
the variable so the user generic waste
automated ways of choosing where to
Branch next okay so picking your
variable
choose a variable minimizing the entropy
of the marginal distribution over its
domain because it makes sense the lower
the entropy the more certain you know
you are you should be certain of what's
going on okay less uncertainty there is
disorder
so that's picking that variable and then
well then for that variable you choose
the value maximizing the marginal with
the highest belief okay that was talking
before well for Value selection
heuristics there's not it's true that
there's way less wisdom so far
that brings an option to distinguish
between values and knowing and deciding
what to branch on next okay
um near uniform sampling
well okay so you want to sample
Solutions of your some solutions or
models depending where you're coming
from
of your CPU formulation or model
uniformly at random well if you let's
say you compute you're given the the
true marginal distributions again so
hopefully you get something close but
there are no guarantees released so
you're not I you can't unless
the constraint graph is is doesn't have
any Loops I mean there are some
characterization but that rarely happens
in practice what helps us here with
respect and I should have mentioned that
with respect to a standard belief
propagation is that our constraint graph
and get a factor graph if you prefer
has fewer Cycles because a lot of the
small Cycles are sort of encapsulated in
those global constraints so that's one
big no the big factor okay so it tends
to behave better if you decompose it all
different uh it won't conversion easily
as as well as what I've shown before
okay so you could say well I pick any
variable I pick a value according to the
marginal distribution which if it
reflects accurately reflects its uh how
it appears in Solutions readjust
distribution and repeat so that
potentially could can help you do
sampling
um and okay and last is something that
we've started looking at uh
neurosymbolic AI so situations where
um
you've got so you you're using neural
networks but in context where there's
there's hard or deterministic structure
structure that you need to respect okay
there are some applications some
examples where that that that's very
important and that's typically can be
quite hard to learn can we use a a a
model driven approach a a one of our
models of that structure CPU or
something else
to help either train or or tune whatever
out the neural network will output
um so combinational solvers in general
can tell you whether or not satisfies a
constraints but that can be expensive to
run
CP can go a little bit further in
polytime typically just saying well at
this value is not supported so it should
be filtered out with the marginals uh
added on well so you get a distribution
over the domain the possible values and
that's sort of a it's much more natural
to integrate it with within your neural
networks I'll give you two two examples
and it runs so this is something that
that you want to do in in polytime as
well
um okay so I've taken this picture from
uh another project but let's just look
at this box here so this box here is a
neural network
it's a generative model so it outputs
it's a sequence of tokens of values and
typically it would so it learns this is
during inference here so it outputs a
probability distribution and it will
sample every step it samples from the
distribution for the next token so that
distribution is different from one token
to the next
the idea here is that well since now
there are cpbp solver is used to
manipulating distributions over domains
well we just input that into our solver
with the constraints and it outputs a
modified probability distribution from
which is then sample that will reflect
what was learned
from the training the Corpus but also
what you can do or what should do
according to the constraints
we've used it also yes that's the output
yeah I've showed you that okay and
we've also used it I started using it
for training here it's a reinforcement
learning framework where you've got an r
a trained RNN and the
um your the agent is being trained to
find to the the uh what's with what has
been learned and here we can
easily since we've got these marginals
approximately marginals over
the action or the value well we can use
that from the CP model to add to the
reward function my apologies if you're
familiar with with the reinforcement
learning to the reward function
uh to help train the the agent further
so it's just
it's it's uh information that's more
natural to integrate into neural machine
learning than than just saying well it's
the binary it satisfies or it doesn't
basically okay so to conclude
so again my message
what's what why does CP stand out I
think is that direct access to problem
structure from the sort of high level
constraints in in the model and the more
you can do with these the more
opportunities you may have so we can do
well I haven't talked about it but we
can we could do stronger search space
reduction so higher levels of
consistency better guidance to find
Solutions I've mentioned that
also resampling natural interface with
neural networks and possibly uh even
more
okay that's all I have to say thank you
This is 40 people they're people from
Zoom so
I was just going to ask if there had
been any formal analysis on the
relationship between marginals and
Optimal Solutions for optimization
problems
um no so so all that I've said
um really holds well for for
satisfaction problems now for
optimization
so you've got well we've done some work
where uh one thing you could do is uh
let's say you're you're uh
uh you're maximizing set a lower bonus
thing I want I'm only interested in
solutions that are at least as good as
that and and and compute margin also for
that uh the um well I won't go back to
that but the minimum spanning tree uh
you sort of get these these marginals
that are
um weighed by the the the quality of the
solution that they're in so there's this
so in some instances there's potential
to get information sort of that's uh
about optimism uh optimization as well
yeah I guess so for optimization when
you impose the bounding constraint on
the objective these branching rules are
helping you find a satisficing solution
for that sub problem faster right right
yeah that's it with Focus you you would
be
directed toward these these better
Solutions right yeah
yeah
cool deep had a question
so uh for the counting queries uh it
looks like you need something
incremental uh or are you after every
decision uses oh yes okay well good
question so this
uh
this is information that you could do at
every node of your search tree now it's
potentially expensive in some cases so
what we've started doing is saying well
if the search space hasn't changed so
much measured in a simple way if the
domains of the variables haven't changed
so much
well you're likely probably you want the
the computation you'll compute something
that's similar to what you had before so
we just reuse these marginals
go down and then when it you decided the
change sufficiently then you can
recompute yeah because there is always a
trade-off right you're working harder
add a note of the search tree to try to
reduce prune your surgery have a smaller
search streak but in the end if you look
at runtime there's this compromise uh
just to follow up are you able to reuse
the information of the marginals you had
you know few notes above or you just
redo fresh oh
and you think
um
yes no yes I am reusing it yeah yeah
so you mentioned about uh dense sets of
solutions which for which you can do the
counting right
um there was
um in the context of the all different
the estimator right for density yes yeah
so what do you do for sparse it's okay
yes I should have mentioned it so
remember we added domain propagation to
the estimator that took care of the bad
special case of the upper triangular
Matrix it also helps you quite a bit for
on sparse I don't I didn't show you some
graphs but it sort of it it improves it
quite a bit of spending the extra time
to do the main propagation at every step
and you get a much better estimator so
for the sparse case is not an issue once
you have propagation but still you need
to sample so that's in practice for the
all different if the number of variables
not too big uh we compute the permanent
exactly but but you know after five six
variables you don't want to do that and
otherwise you use the upper bounds that
I mentioned and because we're taking the
upper bounds are not
so so good but remember we're taking a
ratio of two things and it sort of
cancels out the Badness so in practice
so relatively to one another the the the
the the the uh the bounds are the the
value you get is pretty good and and how
much does it scale to like
constraints with how many variables oh
uh you mean in in all uh
well depend depends very much on on the
problem I mean you it is a bit more
expensive to run so
um what really
kills it uh currently is uh problems
where you have large domains you know
we've got some variables that's
large integers because you need to
maintain and compete information for
every domain value if your domains are
very large
then that that just skills it's it's it
really slows down so we're currently
looking into okay what do you do in that
in that case can you
um
discretize that domain into you know
into uh fewer chunks and compute some
information there not not clear so you
you've got compared to
standard CP you're working harder with
individual domain values you have to be
careful if the remains are very large uh
it'll computation time will just explode
yeah
some work on uh basically using
something like rasmussen's algorithm
uh in a symbolic way like using
algebraic decision diagrams and okay
that kind of stuff uh and that seems to
scale
a little bit better
for for that uh the estimate okay okay
yeah we can discuss offline
one very quick question
I just wanted to quickly ask if the like
method because we've got nice methods
for computing the marginals for the
constraints that you showed uh were
there other constraints have similarly
sort of nice methods for computing yes
several more I can tell you uh those
where we don't have I mean those for
example for scheduling the cumulative or
disjunctive where already as I said
before it's it's
it's not one that's easy enough to do
you can't do our consistency so you do
some filtering Edge Edge finding and
other things but it's not complete
um
well accounting is even harder there
yeah yeah
thanks
thank you
I believe there is no a social event and
possibly a talk by cool Dave
upstairs
um if any of you don't have access the
the stairwell is near where you go in we
can let you upstairs uh and I believe
there's also a music night
afterwards is that going on today